with chris repco a student at the
university of missouri chris first of
all tell us how does it feel to finally
be back here in st louis playing at the
st lucias club
it feels great and i was very upset two
years ago and the event got cancelled
and i'm happy to be here it's good food
here good it's high high quality
tournament good players
we have like six different types of
drinks offered for us to us for free
while we're playing it's very nice
definitely uh the saint riches club
three thing everybody like the
professional that you guys are tell us a
little bit about your uh game it seems
just a spectacular victory for you oh
thank you well i was playing an opening
that i analyzed
with our coach christian
and he thought that it's
not such a good opening but i told him
that i just enjoy playing it and i'm
happy that i proved it to today and i
think that ali marandi confused his
opening prep a bit and that helped let's
actually take a look at that game we're
going to see that on the screen right
there chris let me pull it up i think i
have it up there we go and it must be
this move h4 that you're referring to i
love how leech has already put a tedious
mark on it
exactly yeah h4 i like it
it's
it's not that great for white if
black knows it precisely but i feel like
white gets a small advantage everywhere
and it's an attacking position
a lot of options for both sides
right so take us to a lot of a couple of
the key moments of this game we do have
kind of an unusual setup here for black
right with the early knight c6 95.
that uh if you go back to bish uh yeah
here i know that a good move what i was
worried during the game was that he
would play knight eg4 let me and the
idea here is that the knight will always
have either the g4 square or the e5
square there's no way for me to
to get rid of both and
i looked at this position a while back
but i wasn't exactly sure how to play it
with white so i was worried that he'll
do this and this i i think that is one
of the best things black can do right
instead he put the bishop on g4 a more
ambitious developing move but it became
very awkward for him after bishop e2
bishop takes f3
and it feels like also this move bishop
to g4 commits to uh taking on f3 and uh
relieving the two bishops after bishop
takes f3 because if you take on f3 with
the knight then after g takes f3 you're
losing a tempo you have to retreat with
that bishop and that cannot be good for
black it feels like the move bishop g4
was basically wasted
yeah this didn't appeal to me very much
bishop takes f3 must have confused this
openings because after g takes f3 it's
clear that f4 is coming and as chris was
mentioning it's important to have both
the e5 and g4 squares there under
control it's still possible to play this
with h5
and then i think that after bishop e3 e6
is a strong move or one of the good
moves it's a playable position i would
probably play samsung like king f1 or
and just a normal game but
what he did is he played e6 immediately
which i think he confused his prep
because this cannot be good after f4 h5
and it didn't seem good it seems like
black's pieces are just
too passive the knights are not putting
enough pressure in the center remember
that white has a lot of trumps here they
have
the center they have the pair of bishops
and it's clear that they're going to be
castling on the on the queen side and
immediately they can even push the pawn
to h5 as chris did
breaking open that king side or
harassing the bishop that happened in
the game with the move h6 so let's go
through it a little bit very much lila
style yeah this h5h6 it doesn't seem
like that pawn is going to be a
tremendous asset much more of a
liability but it just uh accommodated
this bishop on f8 tremendously yes
bishop on f8 is just not going anywhere
and actually the way that jj played this
position surprised me a little bit the
move queen f7 i thought castling long
was in the books but he decided actually
i'm going to castle
into uh the jaws of the lion playing
bishop e7 in short castle and the lion
will he close his mouth
yeah pretty much i mean after
i wasn't expecting castle castle short
like after castle long bishop e7 i was
thinking to maybe like play f4
immediately because that would avoid him
playing castle short but i was like no
way like castle short can be good like
i'll play king b1 and if he castle
shorts then i'll be probably happy
anyway
right which king b1 kind of forces him
to maybe castle short because
i'm slowly improving my position while
it's unclear what black can do what were
you planning on doing if he was castling
long
at this point good question um were you
going to take that pawn on a7 you know i
was gonna calculate that bishop a7 was
definitely in
in my thoughts but i don't know if it
works it might work actually a c5
c5 yes
very nice can't take with the knight
because this undefends the pawn on b6
b takes c5 is probably going to get
checkmated by bishop a6 check and the
same applies to d take c5 actually i'm
not so sure about details i'm also not
sure i would be calculating it
after he would play cos along well i
have to say
i don't believe in this for black
at all this looks very very sketchy
perhaps after d takes c5 an interesting
move would be to go queen to a4 yeah i
like queen a4 now if you go king to c7
maybe i can even take on b6
you can take on b6 that might work i was
thinking bishop b5 also works oh my
goodness i think that's okay
b6 works yeah that's just mate bishop b6
is just made right let's show that line
king takes queen a6 check king c7 check
again king c8 and the bishop joins to
freight
with deadly consequences yeah this is
quite lost but castling short wasn't
that good either
the rest was quite
solid a good performance i like this
pawn sacrifice just opening up more
stuff on the king side and at this point
this is just not going to be stopped you
actually want to get rid of the pawn on
h6 for free to allow your rooks to
participate in the attack so there's
very little black can do to defend and
the rest was simple for you chris just
finishing off in style
well a nice victory here with rook jade
of course distracting the rook from the
defense of the queen and and that's all
she wrote well
nice nice early victory here in the
tournament thank you yeah first rounds
are always kind of all over the place so
i'm happy to
get the victory
well chris thank you very much for uh
joining us here in the studio and good
luck in the rest of your game thank you
absolutely all right let us